here's just the stupidity that is going
on in california we showed you this on
monday that on sunday at the big
football game governor gavin newsom and
mayor eric garcetti and san francisco
mayor london breed and magic johnson
they were all at the big football game
and they were maskless they were
massless now i want you to particularly
look at eric garcetti who's standing
next to magic there
because i'm going to get to some video
of him in just a second
and i usually talk about gavin newsom
gavin newsom's just evil he's is what he
is
magic i think if i'm not mistaken magic
because he's hiv positive is a is in
like a higher risk group so is he
supposed to take the mask off or not
it's his own personal choice i'm okay
with magic doing whatever you want magic
is also not a politician locking people
down so magic it's good to see your
smile and uh you know i watch old 80s
lakers vs celtics games and i'm doing
cardio so i've got no problem with magic
johnson but eric garcetti over there the
mayor of los angeles one of the most
locked down
destroyed cities
in all of these united states the city
that i just fled well when he got called
out on smiling with magic johnson
here is the load of bs that he tossed at
you i wore my mask the entire game and
when people ask for a photograph i hold
my breath and i put it here and people
could see that there's a zero percent
chance of infection from that
i mean think how insane we let them get
away with this stuff right
he holds his breath so that means
someone comes up to him someone comes up
to him and says hey uh mr mayor can i
take a picture with you and they're
already in his face at that point right
so then he takes a breath
you've inhaled all of the stuff at that
point you're holding the stuff in you
in your lungs
you liar we let the he takes it off for
the water he holds his breath correct i
was very judicious yesterday uh very
judicious and you'll see the photo that
i did take
where
magic was kind enough generous enough to
ask me for a photograph and in my left
hand's the mask and i took a photo
the rest of the time i wore it
as we all should
not when i had a glass of water or
anything and i encourage everybody else
to do so and
that's it i mean it's just awful you
know he takes it off for the glassware i
mean there's so many videos and pictures
of him just sitting there at the chairs
just you know oh look at me i'm
scratching my head i'm smiling where's
your cup of water dude where's the water
are you just a relentless shameless liar
i think we know the answer
dick these people are clowns ridiculous
buffoons and i wish you luck if you live
in california if you live in los angeles
if you have anything to do that's the
beautiful thing for me i got to tell you
when i lived in california and i would
talk about these people there was a
there was an anger in me about it right
and an uh indignation about it and uh
almost like a complete like how how is
this even possible now it's actually
hilarious there is nothing funnier than
that sort of nonsense to me and now i
want to compare that to what's going on
here in florida because in florida we
have a guy by the name of ron desantis
and ron desantis decided to keep this
state open and this state has incredible
uh has an incredible economy right now
the amount of tourism is exploding there
is construction everywhere house prices
are high because people are moving here
there is it's just good it's just good
and happy and you see people smile and
you see their teeth and it's awesome
here's ron desantis talking about how
he's going to keep our schools good so
that some of these bad ideas that have
infected everything in these blue states
won't infect the free state of florida
so what we're trying to do with the
legislature is give parents the ability
to inspect the curriculum so they know
what's going on in their schools i think
a lot of parents you know have uh very
strong beliefs about you know how what
is appropriate for for school system to
be discussing and certainly in terms of
like trying to affirmatively push kids
in one direction or another in some of
these areas you know becomes very
problematic and i know parents just they
want to have a basic education so what
we want is you know have curriculum
transparency make sure that the parents
are part of this there are people in our
country and in our state who take the
position that that parents really have
no role in this and that they just need
to be kind of in the dark about what's
going on you know we believe sunlight is
the best uh the best disinfectant and i
think that whether it's things like crt
whether it's other things involving
curriculum having that transparency is
something that's very significant
that's my governor that's right that's
right that is a good man right there and
in essence what he is saying is that
your children
are not the property of the state he's
saying yes we should have public
education we we have tax dollars so that
we can have public schools it's a part
of the exchange that we do here in
america and in most societies you pay
some money in so that you hope you can
send your child to a school to get what
he calls quote a basic education and we
did that pretty decently in america for
about a hundred years pretty decently i
would say
i remember going to public school
elementary junior high high school i
went to a public college as well state
university of new york at binghamton i
got a full public education now i'm not
saying i learned everything absolutely
perfectly and i did come out sort of as
a lefty politically so is what it is but
i remember going to school going to
elementary school learning about slavery
learning about racism learning about
civil rights learning about the
holocaust learning about history and you
got a basic education that was honest
that was decent you said the pledge of
allegiance at the beginning america was
good and these were the ideas that we
were talking about it wasn't to it
wasn't to whitewash any of the bad
things that have happened
but it was to give
young people a sense of what you need to
know you learn some basic math where two
plus two equals four not two plus two
equals five which is what we're doing
now with this common core nonsense um so
he's telling you hey we're gonna get
back to the basic stuff and as he says
some parents would like to know what
their kids are learning not because
they're trying to stop their kids from
learning an honest assessment of the
truth but they don't want them to be
brainwashed into all of this gender
stuff in third grade to be taught all of
this crazy gender identity stuff they
don't want to be brainwashed into this
neo-racism that is critical race theory
they want to have a say which by the way
is why all over the country parents are
finally
showing up to school board meetings and
they're fighting back and then of course
the biden administration started calling
them terrorists for doing so um you
would know all about that so it's like
this is good and i just got to say one
more time i am very happy to live in a
place
where we are governed by someone who
doesn't want to rule over us but someone
who wants us to rule over ourselves and
create room to do just that by creating
places of decent education as opposed to
indoctrination